>> Announcer: YOU'RE WATCHING
THE TNT "NBA TIP-OFF" PRESENTED
BY CARMAX, THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
>> HILARITY AND GOOD WILL LAST
NIGHT IN DENVER, THE JOKER WITH
SHOT IN THE BACK TO MARCUS
MORRIS.
>> MARKIEFF MORRIS.
BOTH EJECTED.
NO WORD ON THE SUSPENSION YET.
>> WHICH ONE ARE YOU GOING TO
SUSPEND?
>> COULD BE BOTH.
>> CAN'T JUST SUSPEND THE JOKER.
>> YOU CAN'T?
>> YOU CANNOT WITHOUT SUSPENDING
MORRIS.
>> SHOULD THEY BOTH BE
SUSPENDED?
>> ONE GAME, YES.
>> PROBABLY ONE GAME.
>> I AGREE.
>> BECAUSE OF THE LETTER OF THE
LAW OF THE NBA.
BUT I LIKE THE JOKER.
>> IF THERE WASN'T A LETTER OF
THE LAW, YOU'RE OKAY WITH WHAT
THE JOKER DID?
>> WHAT DID HE DO?
>> GAVE HIM A SHOT IN THE BACK
AND WHIPLASHED HIM, DID HE NOT?
>> GET HIM SHAQ.
>> ERNIE, IT'S CALLED
RETALIATION.
WHEN YOU HIT ME, DON'T TURN
AROUND.
DON'T TURN AROUND BRAD MILLER,
I'M SWINGING, EITHER GOING TO
TAKE IN FRONT OR BACK.
AS BIG GUY WHEN LITTLE GUY HITS
YOU, YOU GOT TO TOUCH THEM BACK.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH WHAT THE
JOKER DID.
I LIKE IT AS BIG GUY.
GUYS FOULING ON YOU, HANGING ON.
HE HIT HIM INTENTIONAL,
UNNECESSARY ROUGHNESS, WHAT DO
YOU DO AS BIG GUY?
HIT THEM BACK.
WHEN YOU HIT ME, DON'T TURN YOUR
HEAD, IT'S COMING, IN THE FRONT
OR BACK.
>> DANGEROUS OR DIRTY PLAY LIKE
ERIK SPOELSTRA SAID?
>> NO, HE'S JUST DEFENDING HIS
GUY.
WATCHING ALL THESE FOOLS ON
TELEVISION TALK ABOUT THIS ALL
DAY.
MORRIS STARTED IT, FIRST, JOKER
RETALIATED.
HIT HIM IN THE BACK.
YOU HIT ME, I'M WITH SHAQ,
BETTER NOT TURN YOUR BACKY.
KENNY MOST MILD-MANNERED DUDE IN
THE WORLD, SOMEBODY HIT HIM --
>> WE SWINGING.
>> WOULD HOPE THAT JOKER COULD
HAVE SELF-RESTRAINT.
>> NO NO NO.
>> HOLD ON.
>> ONE OF THOSE BIG GUYS WITH
RESTRAINT.
>> HE HIMSELF SAID HE SHOULDN'T
HAVE REACTED --
>> I'M NOT SAYING, LET ME
FINISH.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> WE WOULD HOPE.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF WHO HE IS,
POSITION HE PLAYS AND WHAT GUYS
ARE TRYING TO DO, WHAT MESSAGE
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEND, HE SENT
THE BIGGEST MESSAGE.
SO THE MESSAGE IS, USED TO SAY
THAT ABOUT BLAKE GRIFFIN, GUYS
FOULING HIM FLYING THROUGH THE
AIR DUNKING ON PEOPLE.
TRYING TO SEND THE MESSAGE TO
STOP TO HIM.
JOKER IS LIKE IF I FLY THROUGH
HERE, YOU'RE GOING TO GET HIT
NOW.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO PLAY
BASEBALL.
KEVIN McHALE SAID ONE TIME, THEY
WERE PLAYING PISTONS, THEY WERE
BEATING HIM UP.
SAID EVENTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO
PLAY BASKETBALL AND I'M GOING TO
KICK YOUR ASS.
GOT TO GET HIM BACK THE
BASKETBALL OR EVERYONE WOULD TRY
TO DO THAT TO HIM.
>> WE ALWAYS SAY WHAT ABOUT WHAT
MORRIS DID WAS A BASKETBALL
PLAY?
>> NONE, ZERO.
>> WE ALL LOVE SPO AND HE'S
GOING TO DEFEND HIS GUY BUT
NOTHING HE DID TO WAS BASKETBALL
PLAYER.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, AS LEADER HE'S
SUPPOSED TO COME OUT AND SAY
IT'S WRONG TO DO.
BUT EVERY NOW AND THEN, SOMEBODY
GOES OVERBOARD, YOU HAVE TO
RETURN THE MESSAGE LIKE KENNY
SAID, LET THEM KNOW I'M NOT
GOING TO TOLERATE THIS.
>> JEREMY, DO WE HAVE THE SOCIAL
MEDIA EXCHANGE?
THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THE DAY
AFTER, MORRIS WAITED UNTIL HE
TURNED HIS BACK.
NOTED.
>> JOKIC BROTHERS, STARTED THEIR
FEED JUST FOR THIS, YOUR BROTHER
MADE A DIRTY PLAY FIRST IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE A STEP FURTHER BE
SURE WE'LL BE WAITING FOR YOU,
THE JOKIC BROTHERS.
YOU GOT TH